the immigration battle front and center
as the first wave of the caravan is met
with violence in Tijuana Mexico
local residents classroom with the
migrants and chanting this
[Applause]
and potential 20/20 hopeful Kamala
Harris facing backlash after this
exchange during a confirmation hearing
for the nominee to head ice are you
aware of the perception of many about
how the the the power and the discretion
at ice is being used to enforce the laws
and do you see any parallels I do not
see any parallels between I'm talking
about perceptions and agents I'm talking
about perception I do not see a parallel
between what is constitutionally
mandated as it relates to enforcing the
law are you aware that there's the
perceptions you know are you aware that
there's an ice in the same category as
the KKK there's that where you're asking
me no I'm very specific about what I'm
asking are you aware that there's a
perception that that ice is
administering its power in a way that is
causing fear and intimidation
particularly among immigrants all right
he kept his cool there Greg yeah I was
it really I her but I thought that was a
very sleazy sleazy move it's a way of
asking a question without asking a
question some would say Jessie that you
drink heavily
not me but some would say that's what
she did she said she said there is a
perception of what would you say to the
perception and the thing is the only
reason why the perception would exist is
because she is laying the perception out
there you know some may say that ice is
like the KKK
you are the some but you are too
cowardly to admit that you are the some
so I thought that stunk to high heaven
and he answered it correctly I hate mine
and again he's trying to get confirmed
to me that by the way I don't think that
you drink heavily yeah I just I just saw
you in my eye line Barry
no he doesn't shows getting off to a
great start some would say your hair is
beautiful turn to talk okay first of all
comma law what you did I agree you can't
frame the question as guilt by
association I could say there's a
perception that Democrats are Pro crime
and there's a perception that the
Democrats are open borders and and
that's actually there's more of a
perception than that then there's a
perception that ice is akin to the KKK
now she needs to go her history books
the KKK terrorized the South for decades
and hung innocent African Americans they
were supported by the Democratic Party
okay she African Americans senator
should know that and that comparison is
so outlandish and so disrespectful to
the ice agents that are just doing their
job you know who's really scared of ice
and who should be scared human
traffickers drug traffickers criminal
illegals that have skipped bail and are
now still in the United States that
those people should fear ice and there's
a good reason for that Murray your I
will say though that there is a
perception we have seen not based on
what senator Harris said but based on
real people who have come into contact
with ice who are either trying to claim
asylum who've had their compare them to
the KKK I'm not making that comparison
but the the where she took the question
was are you aware there's a perception
that people are scared when these people
have had their children taken from them
some of them don't know where they are
some of the the adults have been
deported back without their children I
think it's a completely fair question to
ask she asked it incorrectly right but
she inserted the KKK when she didn't
need to do that that's fine and I think
she's well aware of the history of the
KKK I should say Jessie I think she
should be more responsible with her let
me say you're focusing on that piece of
it the question that we heard her say
when she expanded on it when she when
she went back and drilled back down was
a completely fair question there are a
lot of people today who are scared of
ice who are fearful because some of the
stories are quite free like because
she's a lawyer you should be able to
answer that edition
that in a court of law or any things
like objection well yes sustained people
might have that perception because of
her rhetoric Nellie because of their
actions they act like the cake they
can't remember that on the border it's
not ice that is separating families
it's the Customs and Border Protection
right ice goes after people who are it
goes after ms-13 in the interior of the
country illegal aliens who are engaging
in money laundering and drug trafficking
that's interior work they're in fact
saving the the immigrant communities
from these beasts that target them like
ms-13 so they're the actual they're the
ones who are you know helping the
average American in general certainly
immigrant Americans so her saying so she
doesn't even really know what Isis doing
this is posturing for 2020 exactly what
she's running for president let me add
that this also was exactly its felt like
the Cavanaugh hearing and it's the same
attitude the same insulting of approach
the same innuendo Americans didn't like
the Cavanaugh hearing that they're
they're not gonna like if this is what
they're going to continue to do for two
years it will backfire
everything will be criticized it and
then say this is like Cavanaugh oh but
it is that's just like Cavanaugh the
cross-party boundaries it's okay he's up
for the position he should get asked
tough questions and I feel real dicey
skidding know getting unfairly smeared
by the media come on they save people's
lives and they say you know live
immigrants wrong and they and they do
these huge round ups of immigrants
across the country in the in criminal
criminal migrants who are that are there
are warrants and that they're not true
they have expanded their power beyond
what they used to have and there are
whole immigrant and you know what if
what you're saying Tammy is true if
that's true he could have taken that
opportunity to say I understand there
are these false fears out there
here's laying the victim Marie just like
Cavanaugh know she she's comparing KKK
she's like what the hell's going on here
could have actually batted down some of
these theories if he doesn't think
they're true I would saying I don't know
what you're talking about he could adapt
ritty good job I flipped out right so
would you know he held his competitors
Murray he how's his composure like you
used to at the podium the State
Department we're gonna switch gears nice
people say I'm good at that
all right there's an ongoing fight as
you know between the White House cNN's
Jim Acosta and earlier today a judge
ruled that the Trump administration must
reinstate his Press Pass Chris Wallace
is sitting down with President Trump
this weekend for Fox News Sunday he
asked him about these latest
developments watch this what they said
though is that we have to create rules
and regulations for conduct et cetera et
cetera we're doing that we're going to
write him up right now it's not a big
deal
and if he misbehaves we'll throw them
out or we'll stop the news conference I
think your rule is gonna be what what is
it that you're saying look this is over
the line and you will have rules of
decorum you know you can't keep asking
questions you have we had a lot of
reporters in that room many many
reporters in that room and they were
unable to ask questions because this guy
gets up and starts you know doing what
he's supposed to be doing for him and
for CNN and you know just shouting
questions and making statements too but
I will say this look nobody believes in
the First Amendment more than I do and
if I think somebody's acting out of
sorts I will leave I'll say thank you
very much everybody I appreciate you
coming and I'll leave all right Greg
this is so perfect because what does
what this is about is a violation of the
Fifth Amendment which is a right to due
process like
here's the point so the so the mean
aggressive so the media is now up in
arms over the violation of due process
because a guy got lost his guard pass
even though he they have daily pass but
they were seemingly very silent when a
guy lost his due process when he was
accused of a sexual assault from 35
years ago by the way I'm for due process
for everything okay
so I think it's far it's glad that
they're finally saying hey new process
yes we love due process the judge did
not rule Jesse on the First Amendment
issue it was this Fifth Amendment issue
sounds to me though like though that the
White House is saying
okay look we've made our point and
Acosta is going to be a Costa but you
might not be well thought of by his
college it's definitely time to move on
considering the judge that made the
ruling was a trump appointed judge but
there couldn't there's not an argument
to saying oh this is an Obama appointed
judge of course I think everybody is
willing now to take a step back I'm just
glad that Donald Trump is restoring
decorum it's about time because the
Democrats and the reporters have been
really running wild and have been
disrespecting the traditions that we so
hold dear in this and it's just a time
glad that this is being restored was not
respecting the dignity of the White
House Donald Trump gonna have to start
House is he gonna have to start acting
with decorum when he's and there's our
perception that he cuts people off when
he calls them stupid and rude is he
gonna have to start playing by some
rules too I don't think I think he was
fine and he said if anybody acts up
we're gonna boot him it was sort of
weird to me to watch Thomas Jefferson
Jefferson pulled a lot of hard back you
mentioned that his colleagues acosta
colleagues don't like what he does and
now they're they're going to be the ones
who are in a way gonna have to be in
charge to get the little child to sit
down otherwise the entire thing will end
and I think that's the power of the
presidency it's it's a perfect way to
handle it and they'll be I think they're
gonna put him in the deep freeze that's
my recommendation yeah I don't put
anybody in the deep freeze we already
hit someone off the plane one no that's
not the deep freeze though no who was it
we pushed them off the table with his
David Gregory no it was David Gregory
wasn't it we had some fun pills okay